look out here come the spider-man
spider-man into the spider-verse what's
the first theatrical movie to crack open
the concept of the multiverse for
spider-man the mcu's live-action
spider-man no way home is following in
those footsteps in a lot of ways
bringing in characters from other
universes bad guys and good guys alright
let's get this out of the way yes andrew
garfield and toby maguire are in this
movie in the roles of peter parker and
peter parker
you're not peter parker
bringing together three different
spider-man makes for a smaller version
of the spider-verse to manifest on the
big screen it also leaves room for the
possibility that other spider-man
variants can enter the picture down the
road we know there's plenty of them
wherever i go the wind follows in the
wind it smells like rain
however there is one face that fans
undoubtedly will expect to show up
sooner rather than later and that's
miles morales he's already led his own
flick and the animated hit spider-man
into the spider-verse which will soon
have a pair of sequels to its name so
when will he make the leap to live
action if a certain no way home easter
egg is any indication it could be right
around the corner they're starting to
come through
but i can't stop them
miles morales may not physically appear
in spider-man no way home but it's made
abundantly clear that audiences aren't
the only ones expecting him to pop up at
the end of the climactic battle andrew
garfield's peter parker reveals his face
to his amazing spider-man 2 nemesis
electro after the unmasking electro
seems disappointed remarking that
because the hero was from queens had a
cool costume and always helped out poor
people he was expecting spider-man to be
black electro's surprise shouldn't be
too
shocking because the villain has never
seen the face of his nemesis before this
interaction it's a humorous moment but
fans of the comic books or into the
spider-verse know there's more to this
line than meets the eye there is of
course at least one black spider-man
miles morales and while he hasn't
appeared in the mcu yet as a live-action
hero it's clear the seeds are being
planted for him to show up at some point
in the future this is far from the first
time miles has been referenced in the
mcu in spider-man homecoming tom holland
spider-man meets aaron davis who is
miles morales uncle within the marvel
canon he and his alter ego the prowler
previously appeared outside of the mcu
in into the spider-verse at one point
during their homecoming interaction
aaron even mentions having a nephew
though he doesn't mention him by name
the other night you told that dude if
you're gonna shoot somebody shoot me
it's pretty ballsy
i don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood i got a nephew who live
here
hopefully the next time the spider-verse
comes into play in the mcu miles can get
in on the action with another mcu
spider-man trilogy on the way there's
more than enough room for another spidey
in this universe i thought i was the
only one
you're like me
i don't want to be i don't think you
have a choice kiddo
as we wait for mars morales to make his
way into the mcu some are wondering is
there another way we might see tom
holland's peter parker take on miles as
a protege maybe in an interview with
sci-fi wire tom holland was asked if he
would ever consider joining the animated
into the spider-verse franchise this
response was clear love them and i'm
just waiting for the phone call while it
may seem like a pipe dream to get an mcu
star into a purely sony project holland
revealed that there have been talks
behind the scenes about getting him into
the spider-verse one way or another he
revealed spider-verse producer amy
pascal actually asked me on the set of
this movie and no one has come back to
me could such a cameo end up in the
upcoming across the spider-verse part
one or two perhaps judging from the
trailer miles morales actually steps
outside of his own reality this time
around traveling through worlds beyond
his own it's possible miles could enter
a live action sphere at some point
briefly meeting tom holland's variant to
say hello or perhaps tom holland
spider-man will enter miles reality and
become animated for a brief period of
time however it transpires elektro's
wish has already come true there is a
black spider-man and he'll be web
slinging his way onto your screens for
years to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one